principle 3.4 remember to reflect when
you experience pain remember this the
pain is all in your head if you want to
evolve you need to go where the problems
in the pain are by confronting the pain
you will see more clearly the paradoxes
and problems you face reflecting on them
and resolving them will give you wisdom
the harder the pain and the challenge
the better because these moments of pain
are so important you shouldn't rush
through them stay in them and explore
them so you can build a foundation for
improvement embracing your failures and
confronting the pain they caused you and
others is the first step toward genuine
improvement it is why confession
precedes forgiveness in many societies
psychologists call this hitting bottom
if you keep doing this you will convert
the pain of facing your mistakes and
weaknesses into pleasures and get to the
other side as I explained in embrace
reality and deal with it
a be self-reflective and make sure your
people are self reflective when there is
pain the animal instinct is
fight-or-flight calm yourself down and
reflect instead the pain you are feeling
is due to things being in conflict maybe
you've come up against a terrible
reality such as the death of a friend
and are unable to accept it
maybe you've been forced to acknowledge
a weakness that challenges the idea
you'd had of yourself if you can think
clearly about what's behind it you will
learn more about what reality is like
and how to better deal with it self
reflectiveness is the quality that most
differentiates those who evolve quickly
from those who don't remember pain plus
reflection equals progress